the christmas season is so nice some say
we should celebrate it twice that's what
we what they are doing at -5 ice bar at
the link promenade jc has more
december 25th is 150 days away but we
are celebrating christmas today here at
the ice bar with their christmas in july
we showed you the festivities outside
now we're inside for the cocktails haley
the master mixologist what kind of
specialties do you have tonight uh so
tonight we have santa's orange kiss
cocktail and then i'll be making a holly
jolly christmas cocktail as well and you
have a couple of guests behind you who
do you have behind them i do have some
guests so this is uh this is slushie the
penguin and then we have the yeti over
here as well two of your mascots that
are always here at the ice bar and we
have our intern brianna it is national
intern day uh i like i like your outfit
i know i think we we match off well each
other you know we've got some color
going with the neon lights looks good we
can go to edc this is actually jackets
they provide you at the ice bar you come
down here your shorts they have nice
jackets to keep you warm how's the
cocktail coming so yummy it's so good
now the glasses here is everything
inside here made of ice complete ice
yeah the glasses are trickle distilled
actually so
very clear and then do you get cold
working inside here very very cold very
very fun though but it is a blast it is
a christmas in july celebration it's a
one day only celebration here at the ice
bar so come down here and join the
festivities at the link over at the
promenade you guys we're gonna celebrate
christmas we're gonna have some
cocktails i'm gonna party with these
three we're having a great time i'm me
send it back to you guys in the studio
what do you say guys
you see ingredients just like